io sto studiando perché domani una
verifica dai oggi stronzo non è vero
guarda che c'è io sono la bravissima
studentessa senti a proposito ma quel
cappello ora quando lo prendiamo
[Musica]
sei la cosa più bella che indosso 6
risorse se il cielo e se il mondo non
hai stabile stella mia sfida grazie
grazie questa la canzone per voi grazie
alla formulazione priva di tensioattivi
aggressivi deterge delicatamente ed è
ben tollerato anche nell'uso prolungato
perché perché non possiamo stare insieme
se quello che voglio io ti amo tu mi ami
allora perché tu sei fidanzato quando le
nostre mani combaciano perfettamente
come due stelle che si incontra lyn
cielo qual è il senso della mia vita
perché alle elementari la mia compagna
di banco mi ha rubato un quaderno non ne
avevo fatto niente mi sposerò mai perché
abbiamo rumori e perché abbiamo due
occhi
eto'o è freddo e mobil home
dell'ospedale cardarelli e house
come hai potuto tradirmi così io ho già
dato tutta me stessa io ho aperto il mio
cuore io ho presentato anche il mio
gatto e tu mi hai lasciato per una
bambina io vivevo per te ma niente
racconto prima o poi quando mi vedrà in
mano per la mano con un altro che non
sarai tu vediamo un po cosa faceva nel
ma chi è questa ti prego guarda come lo
guarda la sicuro la sua ex vediamo si
seguono ancora ma stiamo scherzando
amo ciechi prego lui segue ancora la sua
ex cioè si seguono ancora mamma cosa
significa secondo te scusa
c'è la sua ex e la sorella del suo
migliore amico dai ma io sono rovinata
cioè ci sarà sempre lei in mezzo ma no
no no no qua bisogna far qualcosa cosa
possiamo farlo non è possibile questa
cosa non è un cappello bianco però com'è
possibile che abbia una tetta che
piccola dell'altra ma tanto io sono
normale che
iniziò a sviluppare appunto
dall'immediato dopoguerra i no ai primi
anni cinquanta
[Musica]
praticamente lui già lo sapeva per
quello mi ha scritto
certo è perchè ha scoperto che il sola
la storia continua raccontarli tutti
[Musica]